this is a second thought video made
possible by Skillshare home to over
17,000 classes that could help you learn
a new life skill be one of the first
thousand people to sign up using the
link below and get your first two months
for just 99 cents the universe is
unbelievably massive some predictions
put its scale somewhere around 90
billion light years across provided
expansion has been happening at a fairly
constant rate hidden among this vast
expanse of superclusters black holes
dark matter and other such sciency
things lies a tiny pale blue dot called
earth earth is home to every organism of
every species that has ever lived though
oftentimes a few brave humans spend some
time aboard the International Space
Station which orbits around the planet
since our last trip to the moon we
humans have stuck pretty close to the
earth never venturing very far from home
due to both budgetary restraints and
safety concerns but most of us have
wondered at some point or another how
long until we really start to explore
the universe when will we leave the
solar system for the first time in a
past video we looked at how far humanity
has reached into the depths of space the
long-standing record for the farthest
humans have physically traveled is held
by the crew of the Apollo 13 mission
which traveled around the far side of
the Moon a distance of 400,000 171
kilometers from an Earthlings
perspective but when you're dealing with
interstellar distances it's just a tiny
fraction of how far we'll need to go
just to reach the nearest star our Suns
closest neighbour Proxima Centauri sits
about 4.25 light-years away that doesn't
sound too bad right but when you
consider what a Lightyear actually is
the distance light travels in one year
you realize just how massive a distance
it really is the speed of light is about
300,000 kilometers per second which
means light can travel approximately 10
trillion kilometers per year so four and
a quarter light-years is equivalent to
over 40 trillion kilometres seems like
more of a trip now doesn't it with our
current technology it would take the
very fastest spacecraft ever created the
Helios 2 traveling over 240,000
kilometers per hour over 19,000 years to
get to Proxima Centauri and that's with
an unmanned craft the greatest speed
achieved by a manned vessel was during
the Apollo 10 mission with a top speed
of just 40
thousand kilometers per hour six times
slower than the Helios meaning it would
take over 114,000 years just to make it
to our nearest neighbor star and once
you got to Proxima Centauri you'd still
have about 25,000 light-years to go to
reach the nearest galaxy to ours the
Canis Major dwarf galaxy if you wanted
to reach the nearest large galaxy
Andromeda you'd have to travel 2.9
million light-years to get there it
would take billions of years with
today's technology just to reach the
outer edge of Andromeda but what about
future technology science fiction has
made us hope for the day that warp
drives become a reality allowing space
travelers to bend space and time to
arrive at distant locations at faster
than the speed of light the hypothetical
Alcubierre drive a propulsion method
that would contract space in front of
the vessel and expand space behind it
could in theory achieve faster than
light travel but it's currently
uncertain whether such a drive could
even be constructed so faster than light
travel is off the table for the time
being the upcoming breakthrough starshot
mission will use ground-based light
beams to propel tiny nano craft to
speeds of up to 100 million miles per
hour
which would make a trip to Alpha
Centauri a much more reasonable 20 years
but obviously these tiny ships are much
too small for human passengers so for
the moment we're stuck with our
painfully slow rocket technology unless
we have some major breakthrough in
propulsion technology it just won't be
feasible to launch a mission to another
galaxy if we were to launch an Andromeda
mission at some point in the future when
we had achieved say 50 percent of
Lightspeed capabilities
we'd still have to create a ship that
could support thousands of generations
of humans who would be born live and die
on the long voyage and who's to say that
their vessel wouldn't be passed by a
craft invented even further in the
future that can travel faster even
traveling at the speed of light it would
take over two and a half million years
to reach Andromeda is such a
breakthrough likely in the near future
probably not but then again if you could
go back in time and tell someone from a
couple hundred years ago that we would
successfully land man on the moon they'd
have called you crazy and our rate of
technological advancement is only
increasing who knows what the future
will hold
maybe we'll discover some amazing new
technology that allows humans to truly
set their sights on distant galaxies or
maybe we're destined to be contained to
the Milky Way what do you think do we
have a bright future spanning many
galaxies or are we trapped in our little
cosmic fishbowl let us know your
thoughts in the comments below if you do
decide to take a several million year
voyage beyond the Milky Way why not kill
some time by learning an awesome new
skill with Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
featuring over 17,000 classes in graphic
design animation photography and more
that could help you learn a new life
skill or even start a YouTube channel
like I did a premium membership from
Skillshare is more affordable than most
other online learning platforms and
gives you unlimited access to amazing
classes from experts working in their
fields so you can improve your skills
unlock new opportunities and do the work
you love as a special offer for fans of
second thought you can get your first
two months for just 99 cents when you
sign up using the link below to support
the channel and start learning amazing
new skills make sure to check out skill
share today if you enjoyed this video
make sure to subscribe and click the
little bell to be notified every time a
new second thought video is released
while you're here check out these
playlists full of other great content
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next week